Arthur wanted to investigate how
the amount of exercise he does
affects his weight.
Each week he recorded
the number of hours
he exercised during the
past week and the change
in his weight during that week.
Positive number means
he gained weight.
Negative number or negative
means he lost weight.
Suppose Arthur wants to create
a scatter plot according
to the data presented below.
Complete the sentences below.
The amount of exercise
should go on the-- well,
we want to put the driving
variable on the horizontal axis
and the dependent variable
on the vertical axis.
So the amount of
exercise is what drives
or what in theory drives his
weight gain or weight loss.
So we would want to put the
exercise, the thing that's
driving the other
variable or that
might be driving
the other variable,
that we want to investigate
whether it's driving
the other variable,
we want to put
that on the horizontal axis.
The range of that axis
should be from-- well,
we just have to see what's
his range of exercise
over this investigation
he's doing?
So let's see.
His largest amount of exercise
that he performs in hours
is, let's see,
there's an 8.9 here.
That looks like the largest
amount of exercise he performs.
And what's the least, the
smallest amount of exercise
he performs?
Looks like it's 0.3 is the
smallest amount of exercise.
And so we would want
it to be from 0.3,
or I guess we could go from
0 all the way to-- well,
8 won't be good enough, because
we have a couple of data points
that are at 8-- 8.4, 8.9.
We need to go all the way to 10.
We definitely don't
have to go negative,
because there's no negative
amount of exercise here.
So 0 to 10 should be sufficient.